[Música]
cómo utilizar la herramienta más
importante para lograr hacer lo que
quieran hacer
cuántas veces han pensado en hacer algo
han generado una idea han iniciado un
proyecto y lo aborta no lo concretan se
han puesto analizar por qué algunas
personas logran concretar sus ideas sus
proyectos
todos contamos con la misma herramienta
para poder lograrlo
para poder entender esto es importante
comprender el comportamiento de la mente
y la relación entre la mente y el
cerebro aunque para muchos es lo mismo
no es la misma
la mente
es uno es
y la mente es conciencia no es tangible
no la puedes tocar el cerebro es un
órgano complejo
que le gusta el placer de hecho es
egoísta
le gusta lo fácil
entonces para poder lograr todo lo que
quieras lograr es importante saber
controlar tus pensamientos
hoy les voy a hablar de como
lograr todo lo que quiere hacer con el
poder de la mente voy a iniciar con una
con una historia para una película de
una joven de 26 años
una mujer muy guapa amante del gimnasio
y la yoga
del nombre mariana
era parte de una familia posicionada
reconocida por la sociedad
con ideas anticuadas de las cuales ya no
estaba del todo de acuerdo sin embargo
para la familia mañana era una chica
rara diferente no saben qué pasaba con
ella
mariana se sentía muy presionada ya que
su amiga se casaban
y los padres constantemente le
preguntaban mariana y tú cuando te vas a
casar no te hemos conocido ningún novio
presión familiar y social este
comportamiento y no genera emociones muy
fuertes para mañana
mariana se llevó una sorpresa durante un
chequeo de rutina médica
le diagnosticaron cáncer y era extraño
que una mujer tan joven
que necesitaba su cuerpo y cuidado su
alimentación y hubieran encontrado
cáncer a tan temprana edad
resulta que a mariana lo que le vino a
generar este cáncer fue el mal manejo de
las emociones
él quiere pertenecer a un comportamiento
aprobado por la sociedad
y tratar de satisfacer a sus padres
constantemente por no atreverse a
hablarles con la verdad que sus
preferencias eran diferentes
y que ya estaba en una dieta
después de la ayuda médica y psicológica
mariana logró liberarse de esta terrible
enfermedad y fue cuando decidió
enfrentarse a sus padres y hablarles con
la verdad decirle a su pareja
sentimental era otra mujer
de nombre rosa inés una compañera de la
una ex compañera la universidad los
padres estaban frustrados enojados
molestos
mariana les trató de explicar que ella
gracias al cáncer había aprendido que la
vida le ha dado otra oportunidad para
vivir la vida que ella quería vivir y no
la que otros quisieran que ya vivieron
los padres no entendieron estaban
molestos
a tal grado que él ha amenazado desde
rambla de la familia desde edad
terminaron el chándal echándola y
mariana se fue a vivir a otra ciudad
otro estado por los aires
manera sabía que sus padres eran parte
de su vida trato de reconciliarse con
ellos escribiendo las cartas correos
pero todo fue en vano para los padres de
mariana
ella había muerto
ella pasó el tiempo y reescribir
el tiempo le dio la razón
los padres entendieron que la sociedad
no les iba a reemplazar a su hija
y que mariana era parte de su felicidad
aquí viene el punto culminante de esta
historia
cuando los padres se encendieron después
de mucho tiempo decidieron enfrentar a
mariana con confrontarla y pedirle
perdón
fueron gracias a los modos remitentes de
las cartas fueron hasta el lugar donde
ella vivía
cuando llegaron al edificio por tap set
se toparon con el portero preguntaron
por ella y el portero dice chicas
extraordinarias
se le se extraña muchísimo
mariani los seis meses habían muerto
los padres
[Música]
la pregunta es
porque si en tristeza
cuando les dije que era una historia
para una película no es real
eso es lo que hace el poder de la mente
tú piensas y el cerebro gestiona esa
actividad
la gestión del sistema central
ahora
todo es energía todos somos energía
creo que entiendan este
pero aparte de la naturaleza
todo
fue creado por una mente por un
pensamiento la butaca donde están
centrados
este micrófono
claramente
esta maravillosa tecnología que le
permite
transmitirán en él
nacional
en algún momento
en algún lugar del mundo
alguien lo pienso
y si logro concretar sus pensamientos y
sus ideas
es porque sufrieron utilizar el poder de
la mente
hace unos meses
escribir la historia para una película
de tu ciudad
obviamente era una historia basada en lo
que estamos viendo en la actualidad y
cuando la vi a conocer
no dejaron de llegar los distractores
familiares amigos constructores y está
en plena cuarentena de hacer esto y mi
cerebro
es flojo y miedoso me decía no lo hagas
te puede dar hobby
va a ser más difícil cuando se
reproducía regularmente pero yo siempre
mantenía mis pensamientos en alta
frecuencia
y pensaba positivamente los actores no
pueden ir al set bueno nos vamos a la
casa de los actores
pero es que no te van a permitir entrar
si no te haces el hobby todos los días
entonces hacemos el poli todos los días
pero para poder hacer eso tienes que
éste certificar de kobe 19 el receptivo
móvil 19
mi cerebro me veía porque es
está aquí
este
y me dice estás
loco
y claro aunado a los familiares ya los
colegas
pero nunca le cede el pensamiento era
más poderoso
entonces después de que logré reunir
actores de talla internacional
como danny trejo al cierre es una anchoa
de castellón
lorena herrera armando hernández
ninelconde platanito el teacher
formación a algunos
y estoy actualmente en postproducción de
la película escándalo sector pena 49
lo que les quiero decir con esto es de
que si ustedes hacen las cosas con
pasión en realidad las desean y la
decretan
pueden largar lo que quieran con el
poder de su mente
ahora esto de la pandemia vino a cambiar
el mundo
pero sin saber en la industria que está
a lo que se dedican
les aseguro
que se abre un mundo de oportunidades
para todos
todo
todo tiene que ver como personas las
cosas y como las pinzas
entonces para que funcione esto del
poder de la mente
qué es lo que tenemos que hacer
primeramente insisto en que hagas las
cosas con pasión que te guste lo que vas
a hacer y que te diviertas haciéndolo
algo
o alguien te está distrayendo de tus
pensamientos que se están acercando cada
día tu objetivo es de un lado
no los frecuentes no les cuentes no les
compartas tus ideas
recuerden que más se mueve la gente de
envidia que de cáncer
no permitan que nada ni nadie les quite
energía
ra para que entiendan esto muy bien les
voy a platicar rápidamente cómo funciona
el cerebro
el cerebro así es como le dije
solo piensa el placer es flojo entonces
si entienden esto estarán de acuerdo que
cuando me hice en un proyecto
fácilmente es nuestra propia mente la
que nos puede alejar para poder
concretar ese proyecto ese pensamiento
entonces que hay que hacer cambiar esa
manera de pensar por pensamientos
relacionados con nuestro objetivo
solo así van a poder lograr lo que
quieren hacer si aprenden a controlar
sus pensamientos
van a poder
lograr lo que quieran hacer
hay personas que han logrado hacer cosas
maravillosas
porque aprendieron a controlar sus
pensamientos
aprendieron de aprender a emprender no
sólo eso
aprendieron de sus errores para hacer
las cosas que es mejor hasta que
lograron hacer lo que querían hacer y
dejando un gran legado
walt disney
walt disney tuvo más de 300 errores en
su carrera
aprendió de cada uno de ellos
se impulso para hacer las plantas cada
vez mejor
hasta que logró concretar sus
pensamientos que lo conocemos hoy en día
como el mundo 16
steve jobs
gran emprendedor
de grandes inventos
él tuvo vivió la lección una lección más
fuerte es que te puedes enfrentar en tu
vida que lo hayan despedido de la propia
empresa que él había creado
app
sin embargo eso no lo limitó ni lo
intimidó al contrario lo impulsó para
crear next una empresa que
posteriormente la adquirió pato y cuando
regresó a japón
cambio la imagen de apple y la convirtió
en empresas que ustedes se conocen
jeff bezos
cuando inició su emprendimiento él tenía
el 30 por ciento de posibilidades de
salir adelante
estaba destinado al fracaso 70 por
ciento le había en carácter que iba a
fracasar
su manera de pensar
su manera de reinventarse de adaptarse y
de implementar sus pensamientos lo llevó
a hacer la empresa una de las empresas
más grandes del mundo
y considerado hoy en día el hombre más
rico del mundo
quieren lograr todos sus pensamientos
hay que enfocarse en lo que quieren
hacer
tu mente puede ser tu mayor obstáculo
o tu mejor aliado
tú decides tus pensamientos
negativo o positivo baja frecuencia o
alta frecuencia enfócate en tu propósito
y aprovecha el poder de la mente para
lograr todos
[Aplausos]
[Música]